Thank you Peter.
Welcome everyone.
I am joined by Sanjida Rangwala and Valerie
Schneider is on the phone.
She is the lead of the group who works on
the sequence viewers at NCBI.
The idea is to advertise the fact that we
now have track hubs available in NCBI's data
viewer.
And give a demonstration of how to find track
hubs and connect them and see what they look
like in the displays.
Today's topics will be what is a track hub?
Maybe some of you don't know.
I will give a very brief introduction to that.
And I will show you how you can search for
them within the Genome Data Viewer and a bit
on how to connect to those and display them.
Then I will jump into the viewer into a live
demo, emphasizing some of the features.
I will wrap up with some general features
of the Genome Data Viewer such as how to Sheriff
your browser view once you have configured
it.
What is a track hub?
I put this reference up here for two reasons.
It is a great source of background information.
If you aren't familiar with them, this is
a good place.
It reminds me that track hubs are not an NCBI
project.
These were developed by the good folks at
UCSC.
From a users point of view, the track hub
is a method of displaying annotation data.
These data can be epigenomics, they can be
proteomics, they can be expression data, features
like transcription start sites, that sort
of thing.
These are typically pretty large files in
formats like bigBed and bigWig and BAM.
The real advantages of track hubs is that
the data are on a remote server, relative
to you, so you don't have to maintain the
data.
Also, whenever you ask the browser to retrieve
a certain bit of data it only has to retrieve
what is being displayed in your browser at
the moment.
That range of genomic coordinates.
It does not have to pull everything that is
in the project.
It only pulls what it needs to show in that
particular view.
That makes loading the tracks pretty fast.
As more and more track hubs have become available,
there needed to be a way to organize them
and have a good search interface.
So the Track Hub Registry came into being,
primarily from the folks at EMBL-EBI.
I encourage you to look at this website, www.trackhubregistry.org
to get more background.
I good point of the Genome Data Viewer is
we provide a search interface so you can easily
search the Registry using free text.
I'm going to start on the Genome Data Viewer
homepage.
I've blown up the section on the right where
you can choose the assembly.
You do need to make sure you are working in
the correct assembly version for the annotation
data you want to use.
The data is of course mapped to a particular
version.
The track hub registry has many different
organisms and it often has more than one assembly
for a given organism.
Make sure you choose the correct assembly.
Once you do that you can either click on the
Browse Genome button or use the search box
above to locate a particular chromosome or
region on a chromosome or gene or something
like that.
Let's say you click on that browse genome
button, you will get a view like this.
On the left-hand side of the page are what
we call widgets.
There is a search widget and a blast widget,
and the one we'll be talking about today is
the user data and track hubs widget.
I'll expand that a bit.
Within it is an options menu.
You can see it expanded on the right.
Under options is a selection for track hubs.
This is also where you could load up your
local files of user data.
If you click on track hubs that will take
you into a track hub configuration menu, where
you can start your search, and here you can
input the URL for the hub if you know it.
You can also restrict by datatype, genomics,
transcriptomics, proteomics.
In many cases just searching any of those
is fine.
Let's say I wanted hubs associated with the
Gencode project.
I could simply type gencode in there, hit
Go, and on this day, that retrieved three
different hubs.
Keep in mind this is from the GRCh37 or hg19
assembly.
So you have gencode related data of different
types, long non-coding RNA RACE data, predicted
microRNA target sites, and a project called
PhyloCSF.
Let's say I'm interested in that, and check
that box, it changes the display of the menu
and lists all of the tracks in that hub.
I will share this in more detail when I get
into the live demo.
At the bottom of that list, it also shows
you other assemblies on which the track hub
is available.
It is difficult to tell on the slide, those
are grayed out because they would not be able
to display in this assembly.
At least you know they are available.
There is the other human assembly, the current
assembly, and then assemblies for mouse, chicken,
fruit fly, and C elegans.
When you select the tracks you want to load,
you just check a box for the ones that you
want, you get a nice green light on the right
when the tracks load up, and then you hit
the configure button, and it adds those tracks
into the bottom of your view.
Those should be displaying as green tinted
tracks, they are not on my monitor for some
reason.
And those two tracks at the bottom, the two
that I had requested, I have zoomed in to
a particular gene.
If we want to look at that in more detail
we can zoom in farther, we see here that the
donor predictions are lining up at one end
of an exon, and the splice acceptor predictions
at the other.
That looks good.
That is all I had to do for the slides.
I'm going to jump into the Genome Data Viewer
and do a live demo.
Here I am on a browser in the Genome Data
Viewer.
I want to back up a bit and give you perspective
on why we think using track hubs is important.
Let me increase the zoom level on this page.
You see up here at the top, we have this nice
array of over 600 eukaryotic RefSeq genome
assemblies and their annotation.
As more people put data into track hubs, you
will be able to align this other source of
data in the same viewer with the NCBI annotations.
The goal is, having two or more different
sources of annotation, might be able to come
up with some new insights or make better annotations.
That is the overall goal.
With that introduction, I will jump into the
Genome Data Viewer and see how the track hubs
can help facilitate that goal.
I am going to choose GRCh37.
There are many more hubs available for GRCh38,
but I'm just using this as an example.
I'm going to click on Browse genome.
That is loading the page.
As always the viewer comes up with a default
set of tracks.
I am going to close a couple of these widgets
right now.
And open up this user data and track hubs
widget.
I have no track hubs or other tracks right
now.
If I want to go to that configuration menu
I go to options, and click on track hubs.
Now I can search for any number of things.
This is a very versatile search interface.
Let's say I want to pull up that PhyloCSF
project and I don't remember the whole name.
I can use wildcards.
So phylo asterisk and hit Go, and it finds
that project for me.
That's a nice feature.
Now, I check that box and again you are going
to see the list of tracks that are available
for this hub.
We have bigBed, and bigWig in this set.
Some of these tracks are in red.
When a provider puts together his track hub
and submits it to the registry, you can mark
a certain set of tracks as the default set.
All of these in black are the defaults set.
These others are not marked as default but
you can indeed load them up if you want.
Maybe these are some type of supporting data,
for example this phylo CSF power is a measure
of that metric's, statistical power.
That is what the red color is about.
Here are the other assemblies I mentioned.
Let's pick the phylo CSF novel set.
So I'll check that box.
You get some configuration options.
You do notice that you get this green dot,
those of you paying attention will see the
track validated with issues message.
We will fix this.
This is an issue only with chromosome M, mitochondrial
genome.
It won't affect the ability to load up a track
for nuclear genome.
That looks good.
I will go ahead and click configure.
Before we look at the sequence viewer, I want
to point out, on the left, it now displays
that track that I loaded.
There is a handy description link.
If you want to learn more about this particular
project, you can click on description and
this is provided by the hub provider, and
so each of the different types of tracks are
discussed here and so we see that this Novel
track for instance, shows potential protein
coding regions that are not currently annotated
as protein coding exons.
So that's what this track is about.
I will clean up some of the tracks.
We see our PhyloCSF novel regions track at
the bottom.
By default the viewer comes in, at least for
you human, showing all of human chromosome
1.
Let me get rid of some other tracks.
I can get rid of that one also.
You may or may not know, you can also move
tracks around.
If I want to put this hub track up there below
the genes a track I can do that.
Let's say I want to focus in on a particular
gene region.
I can go back up to the search widget.
Let's look for the CSK gene.
The c-terminal src kinase gene.
So it is now going to focus on that region.
Here we have our track hub.
I moved it up so that it is in between these
two.
These are the features that come with this
track.
You can mouse over them and get more information.
If you want the exact sequence you can get
that out of here with the FASTA view.
These are colored differently based on the
strand they are on.
I think green is plus strand I think red is
minus.
We see some features in this gene that are
showing up in regions, some are, some are
not, in regions that are currently annotated
as protein coding.
This is a 5-prime UTR region up here.
You can zoom around in the browser if you
want.
You can zoom out and see what this looks like
on nearby genes.
Let's do another search and add another track.
I could go back either to this track hubs
menu, or I could just click on this configure
button.
That will get me back into this search interface.
I can close this up if I want to clean it
up.
To do another search all you have to do is
click on this magnifying glass.
Let's say we want to add a track for epigenomics,
type that in there.
And so in GRCh37 it shows us four tracks.
I'm going to ultimately pick this top one
here, the Cotney lab, but I want to show you
another feature.
Let's say I am interested in looking for DNAse
signatures, so I can just search for dnase.
In this assembly it does not come up with
exactly the same set but it does include the
Cotney lab.
I will check this one for the Cotney lab and
we will connect to that one.
Now we see all of the tracks available for
that.
Many are not part of the default set.
There is a large number of possibilities to
choose from.
You can narrow things down by closing these.
I am not sure what other genomes this is available
on.
We can go down to the bottom.
It is also available for mouse.
Let me go back up to the top.
Let's put up this, impute_CS17-combined_DNase
track.
It's a bigWig track, not a bigBed track, so
I check that, we have the green light, and
I will click configure.
Now it is added in this track.
If I want to go back and look just at the
CSK gene I can use the Region menu and say
go to gene with pad, pad it just a little
space on the said.
Now, let me move this track up now, so it's
right under our annotation.
It is right under the ensemble annotation.
We have a nice signature here, right at the
beginning of this 5-prime UTR.
These show up pretty nicely in the surrounding
genes as well.
That is the basic idea.
You can add multiple tracks that way.
And you still have the options of configuring
in a couple of different spots.
Let's do one more thing.
Let's say we want to look at this PhyloCSF
in Drosophila for the same gene.
I will right click on the title and open a
new browser window.
For the GDV homepage.
I have to make that smaller.
Now I want to search in fruit fly.
There is only one assembly in fruit fly so
I don't have to worry about that.
So I just click on browse genome.
Let's narrow that to the same gene region
in the search box.
So we have the CSK gene here.
Let me clean this up a bit.
When I open up the track widget, let me zoom
in a bit.
I should already have that PhyloCSF track
available because I called it up earlier.
So I can select that.
And I can get a description or I can just
say configure.
That will take me into the menu.
Now I am looking at the dm6 genome annotation.
I will check that box, I get the green light
so I click on configure.
There we have a very similar sort of annotation.
It's in a different spot, but it is amazing
that the CSK is this well conserved between
human and fly.
If I wanted to I could move that up again.
That is it for the demonstration, and I just
want to show you a couple more things, general
features in the browser.
Let's say you get this configured exactly
the way you want and you want to show this
to one of your colleagues.
There is a link up here, let me zoom in on
this.
The link up here at the top of the browser
called share this page.
So you click on that and it will generate
a URL.
So you send that URL to one of your colleagues
and they will see the exact same view that
you are seeing here.
Another thing you can do is use the tools
menu.
Let me scroll over here a bit.
Here you can print this as a publication quality
PDF.
And send that to somebody.
I don't want you to get confused on the share
this page like.
Within the sequence viewer help, there is
a Link to View.
You could use that and it will still display
the same tracks.
But it will just be the sequence viewer, not
the whole Genome Data Viewer.
You won't have the widgets.
So, I am finished with my bit.
We will open it up to see if there are questions.
Any general questions Peter?
[Peter Cooper] there are no questions right
now.
Please be sure, if you think of anything,
writes to us.
I think Wayne has a slide with contact information.
If you have questions about the Genome Data
Viewer or the webinar program in general,
write to us.
Also, some useful ... it will Sherry screen.
Some useful links for good resources for learning
about NCBI, especially NCBI insights.
You can sign up for announcements and check
out our YouTube channel.
This video will live on that YouTube channel
after we get process.
Thanks for coming and we will talk to you
next time.